うーん上野毛自分で切ったらこんなのになっつっ
なぁ買ってしまったようなお値段始まる600センサてねこれ開封の前ができません
9万円はちょっとにダメだ親が怒れ
ブーバーやばいやばいやばいじゃあマージかにょ動画サムネとタイトル見たらわかっ
てるんだけども
とまぁこちら dominator
でございますあの昔動画で紹介したと見てってありますこちらのにいい
これですらもうにばんえんしてるんですよこれまで結構良い作りになってるんですよ
このドミネーターもかなり良い造りだったんがぁ
こちらでおがっちろんですわ
が積んではないですが積んではないんですけど月もに近い変形するタイプが販売された
らしいです
つねもりあかねちゃんファンとしてはね買うしかなかったこれでたらこの発砲予算は俺
の4倍の音なんですよね妄想でビビってますじゃあカーン
ポンッ
やべえ壁がついてきてはないねぇ
ブーバーバッジバッテリーだけちょっと寸しますねドミネーターと
はアニメサイコパスにて犯罪傾向の強い人間を排除するために使われるもので
前も説明したんですけどこれを人に向けるとその人の犯罪係数がわかると
4犯罪係数が安打20宿命だったので攻撃しないという感じで
大
新高台寺店
オーバー109重大犯罪者等犯罪県勢が堺とこれでこのスーパーできるとそんなに高く
なかったらたらないザッツってアイトス日でさせるめっちゃ高くのエリミネーターつで
相手は排除しますそうなるとをが地図羅ちゃんぴ
で変形してね中みたいに変形するんですけどこのおもちゃだとならないんですよ
ところが変形するらしいです
9はこれがこれ立も喉日で縦ございますそんなに音さはない
このこのこのこのペロ乱歩のペロン取りたいんだけどこれセローそれはいいケロロ
引っ張っていい ahkah アーカーん23や早くと本間の飛び出た使ってみたん
ですけどまぁ重大どれくらい貼ってばいいのかなぁ充電町
ここから入れますごバッキリ者やバケバケすば穴じゃねえ方だよなぁこの漢字だけじゃ
いう理由をやるんだけど飽きてきた音響キャバってきましたこれを三部という
配分は今誓った
いっ
うおっ
おっん
移動しましたっけ
中央を動かしてください
今聞いた声がでこういうこっそりキレイなんですよさ問題小川ですどうすればいいです
か
本体が水平になるようにクレットでもしっかり塗ってください ok に切れました
トリガー版を整理してみましょうえっ
美味しい私じゃですね
ff 2分
しちゃ一緒じゃねーっ
しています
ウェビックへスターうわぁじゃないでさぁ
待って来い来い来いコンポはいくかが勝ちじゃあ今と連携しちゃったよ
ちょっとは手取りがおそらく何か出るのかな
big でしたうわぁこれすごいならこの状態が張らない皿せる
ファンクラッチ半からつじゃねーやトリガー遊び問うと
どうぞ
car
を消したらよって
早朝生じた
かっこよこれで胸前を定めて押すとあ
んっという感じでございます近くでちょっとエレベーターモードにしてみましょう
いきますしっこ
バッハ
幸せ5一閃装備ネーターこれ本も.あじゃあさっそくつけてなやつを1人
やってしまいましょうか
てめーだ医師やつぶさたけうっき
えっ嘘ですよねしっぱぎです
お前を見たときから se と思っていたです食べ
指令
dan ん